well the dollar is very interesting and
it's subtle there's a I think an
inherent tendency if you're in American
too thick yes
strong dollar that's good it was strong
though that means America is strong and
and we're kind of proud that the dollars
the world's money that international
transactions are done in dollars and it
certainly makes life easy for us because
we can borrow in our own currency and we
we sell in our own currency it just
makes like these but actually one the
role of the dollar is increased becoming
increasingly problematic because there's
so many dollars out there we have such a
huge international debt and foreign
banks are holding so many dollars that
the banks the foreign banks are
beginning to scratch their heads a
little bit and say we you know all these
dollars represent a promise of payment
by the United States but there's a lot
of them are are they really gonna pay
all this aren't they going to inflate
this away as most big countries do when
they get in trouble but even more than
that is the following situation the
dollar is a floating fiat currency so
it's not linked to gold or silver or any
other commodity it's just the dollar
it's just a promise of the Full Faith
and Credit of the United States now what
that means is that in international
markets countries like China can
intervene in currency markets they can
buy dollars which tends to raise the
price of the dollar and reduce the price
of the yuan which effectively reduces
the price of their exports so it's a
kind of a subsidy to their exports so
they can intervene to keep the dollars
strong which then accelerates
their exports into the US market
it allows them and effectively to over
produce and to over export we
interestingly on the other hand because
as long as the world will accept dollars
deficits really don't matter to
Americans as long as the world will take
dollars we can just printing keep
printing dollars and say hey we want
more oil here's a few more green pieces
of paper with presidential pictures so
it allows us to be irresponsible it
allows us to over-consume overspend and
over borrow and as a result kind of both
we and our trading partners are acting
irresponsibly and that means the system
is not sustainable and we just saw in
this crisis one element of what can
happen when the system becomes
unsustainable and as I said earlier we
haven't really fixed up so it's still
unsustainable and what can happen is
that we could get into a situation in
which other countries just say hey you
know we can't keep taking all these
dollars we don't want dollars anymore
and the oil-producing countries for
example maybe they say look you know
we're just choking on dollars here we'd
rather be paid in a combination maybe
some dollars but some euros and some and
some yen or something like that or what
we find that happening right now is that
countries with large dollar holdings are
trying to diversify so China is buying
agricultural land in Africa or oil wells
in other parts of the world and other
countries are investing in commodities
but they're trying quietly to kind of
get away from the dollar so the
long-term prospect here is that at some
point the dollar is likely to devalue
and the living standard of Americans
we're living above our means right now
we're living beyond
and so the living standard of Americans
is likely to decline